der weiße zwerg mit der bezeichnung sdss
york 12 28 plus 1040 ist nicht allein
ein britisches forschungsteam hat jetzt
ein bis zu 600 kilometer großes objekt
entdeckt dass die sternleiche in rund
zwei stunden um läuft extrem und extrem
seltsam was kann das sein
ein planet ist es nicht höchst
wahrscheinlich besteht es aus metall und
es ist enormen gezeiten kräften
ausgesetzt was passiert da klick
substanzen fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes seines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen weiße zwerge das
sind quasi sternleichen die sich am ende
der entwicklung von sternen bilden auch
wenn sie etwa so groß sind wie die erde
vereinigen sie eine gesamte sonnenmasse
in sich anfangs beträgt ihre
oberflächentemperatur unglaubliche 10
bis 100000 kevin grad celsius ist das
ein ähnlicher wert bei diesen hohen
temperaturen war
doch weil sie über keine zusätzliche
energiequelle mehr verfügen kühlen sie
langsam aus und sie enden als schwarze
zwerge das passiert innerhalb von vielen
milliarden jahren
solch ein weißer zwerg befindet sich
auch im sternbild löwe seine offizielle
bezeichnung lautet sdss j 12 28 plus
1040 auch er hat etwa die größe der erde
und vereint 70 prozent der sonnenmasse
aufgefallen war er dem britischen
forschungsteam weil sein spektrum bei
den analysen die emissions- linien von
kalzium offenbarte die fachleute
beobachten den weißen zwerg schon seit
15 jahren unter anderem mit dem teleskop
gran telescopio canarias auf der kanaren
insel la palma sein spiegeldurchmesser
beträgt 10,4 meter und die arbeit hat
sich gelohnt denn jetzt steht fest der
weiße zwerg ist nicht alleine die
experten und expertinnen haben mit hilfe
von spektralen analysen einen begleiter
der stern gleiche dingfest gemacht es
handelt sich um ein objekt das bis zu
600 kilometer groß ist den weißen zwerg
mit einem abstand von nur einer halben
million kilometer in rund zwei stunden
um läuft also nicht 365 tage wie zum
beispiel bei unserer erde der fall ist
in kosmischen dimensionen ist diese
distanz quasi nichts und so wirken
gigantische gezeitenkräfte auf ihn ein
nach angaben des forschungsteams kann es
sich deswegen nur um ein äußerst metall
reiches massives objekt an das diesen
gezeitenkräfte überhaupt
standhalten kann denn normalerweise
müsste jedes objekt das sich einem
weißen zwerg so nährt
auseinandergerissen werden zum vergleich
wenn es sich bei der konzentration um
unser sonnensystem handeln würde würde
sich der begleiter innerhalb der
sonnenoberfläche bewegen fest steht
jedenfalls dass die strahlung des weißen
zwergs das objekt so sehr auf das
material verdampft so bildet sich ein
gelber schweiz
doch wobei handelt es sich bei diesen
begleiter die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vermuten dass es sich um
einen planeten rest handelt konkret
könnte es der metallischen kern eines
ehemals größeren felsplaneten sein also
quasi unsere erde befreit von den ganzen
steinen und nur noch der metallkern die
forschungsthemen zufolge könnte dieser
bei der entwicklung seines
zentralgestirns werk zerstört worden
sein
heißt also im klartext der weiße zwerg
hat die äußeren felsigen schichten
weggerissen so dass nur noch der
metallischen kern über blieb spannend
ist vor allem das verfahren das die
forschungsgruppe angewandt hatte um den
begleiter überhaupt erst aufspüren zu
können denn direkt sichtbar ist er
aufgrund seiner direkten nähe zu dem
weißen zwerg nicht was erschwerend hinzu
kommt von der erde aus gesehen läuft der
nicht vor dem zentralgestirn so könnte
man ihm also auch durch eine immer
wiederkehrende verdunklung nicht
aufspüren und so halfen sich die
fachleute mit einer spektralanalyse also
da man wird das licht analysiert hier
konnten sie rätselhafte periodische
verschiebung der kalzium emissions-
linien beobachten um periodische
verschiebungen sprechen für ein
umlaufendes objekt genau genommen ging
es hier um die sogenannten
akkretionsscheibe die dafür sorgt dass
immer zum material auf die oberfläche
des weißen zwergs heruntergeht diese
aggression scheibe rotiert
charakteristischer weise um ein
zentrales objekt und transportiert also
akkreditiert materie in richtung des
zentrums nur weil also immer neues
material nach strömt ist dieses
überhaupt erst ins spectrum sichtbar
denn solche schweren elemente singen
aufgrund der schwerkraft direkt ins
innere der stern gleiche die rätselhafte
spektralen verschiebungen diese
regelmäßigen die das forschungsteam
beobachten zu können der aktuellen
studie zufolge einzig und allein mit der
existenz eines objektes mit geringer
masse erklärt werden dass den weißen
zwerg
läuft das nun erstmalig angewandte
verfahren hat großes potenzial denn es
könnte astrophysikern und physikerin
weltweit eine große hilfe dabei seien
weitere begleiter von weißen zwergen zu
entdecken und so könnten dann auch
weitere rätsel zum schicksal von
planetensystemen gelöst werden es ist
wirklich irre was da draußen im weltall
so alles passiert vielleicht können ja
zukünftige generationen dorthin reisen
und solche phänomene selbst erforschen
das wäre ein fantastisches zeit also
unmöglich wäre das vielleicht so
generation schiffes leben und sterben im
all
draufklicken anschauen und raumzeit
block der zukunft abonnieren ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran